she was foxnews biggest primetime star
and she me to draw a leaf or me to was a
thing megyn kelly is I'm glad you got a
warm round of applause I love that movie
before I get to that I just want to ask
you this presidential campaign you
covered a few of them I know when I'm
off and lots of stuff is happening it
kind of eats at me are you miss being on
the air
no because it's very easy to keep up
with the news because it's ubiquitous
right it's Trump Trump Trump your side
of it it's everyone missed that I guess
I miss you had a big voice I I miss sort
of being a voice of reason in the storm
right you know because there's so much
hysteria in the media for and against
and I when I left the Kelly file I I
remember feeling like I might have a
societal obligation to stay because I I
did owe it to my audience to separate
the wheat from the chaff and I thought I
did a good job of it but I have three
little people who I owe more to in my
apartment and Joe Jones I don't have
children
actually I do
about it but but that's you and that's
more important is much like looking
after a bunch of children but I'm doing
the real thing but I saw the I watched
bombshell very entertaining and you know
you cannot very well in it I mean I said
you know you me too to guy but this is a
long time before me too and this is
literally what it was
gretchen carlson is out there saying
roger ailes did that and then they're
looking for somebody else to go me too
because if somebody else doesn't she's
hung out to dry so you gotta feel kind
of good about how they portrayed you in
the liberal media I mean look I didn't
know what to expect cuz I I have nothing
to do with the movie and you know I I
didn't know what was going I didn't know
where name is shooting or anything that
there was a an incident early on where
my mom who lives in upstate New York
where I'm from called me up but she said
why don't you tell me they were making a
movie about you I'm like ma I don't know
anything about it she goes how much
stormy Daniels to play me
I have no clout she didn't get a role
she was disappointed and then she tells
me she goes when I stood up in the
theater and told everyone I was your
mother they said very nice things about
you I'm like oh for the love of God so
anyway it look my takeaway on it is the
movie was a force for good because it
helps shine a light on how it's done how
women who may not be that well connected
you know Gretchen and I we don't really
know each other you haven't spoken since
before we both left Fox but you had that
in common you both had to twirl for
roger ailes
i mean that's you know i posted this
responsibility to channel to the movie
and i did that because i wanted just to
have my response contained in one place
i don't want to keep talking about this
movie over and over and I did it with
women who went through what I went
through
but the twirl was demeaning and
especially if you have a law degree well
that's the thing I mean I argued before
courts of Appeal across the country I
was covering the US Supreme never
twirled for them I mean and you earn
your way up and like the thing about the
twirl is and a lot of other bad worse
things happen to me than the twirl but
the thing about the twirl is it is it is
about seeing your ass it's about
demeaning you it's about
subjugation it's about can I control you
so I've heard you say media is broken
what what do you mean by that
where do you go with that I mean you
know it's true right like it just yeah
the media is so messed up yes it's
disheartening to me and I've felt this
way for a long time not not not just
since Trump and I know you know Trump's
rhetoric is too strong an immediate
people and all that and I know why he
says it there's still amazing
journalists out there doing great work
but the media is completely biased and
what's happened now as I lawyers
politically Oh 100% yes but you work for
Fox News oh I think there's an another
side to the story on bail of course but
the Fox News was born and did so well
because it was the only voice offering
the other side of the coin the rest of
the media was biased toward you know
what the media is biased towards money
they're biased toward money and conflict
because that's what sells I know I don't
think I like I was watching the Virginia
rally this week that there was a gun
rally it was peaceful and you could see
how disappointed the media was that the
civil war didn't break out right right
of course that's what I think the media
bias more it's more than Paula to know
because look I think there was a liberal
slant in the media even before Trump got
in there but he went in there and now
like take CNN he came in there and said
CNN is completely biased to the left
there they're lefties there they're
completely against me and my take on it
was in the beginning he was wrong CNN
wasn't that way I used to watch sanon
all the time when I was at Fox when I
was getting ready for the Kelly file I'd
have on CNN and I'd watch a lot of their
shows and I like a lot of the anchors
over there but my view is CNN became the
thing Trump said they were and they
weren't and now they are now there
they're indistinguishable from MSNBC but
you have to you have to admit it's very
hard to cover a guy like Trump who does
awful things
oh you do agree I agree yes okay well
then you're gonna look left-wing no
because you're saying you were wrong I
totally disagree with you when I was on
doing the Kelly file at primetime 9:00
p.m. on Fox News he was attacking me for
nine months straight right saying
outrageous things it took everything in
to go out on the set night after night
and not make it personal and not have a
vendetta against him and not the overly
harsh on him because of what are you
doing to me my family but I did it it's
doable you just have to remember it's
not about you right it's about the
audience and that's truth so here okay
and you know what what's great is you
know what I keep saying all year long
you know you can hate Trump you can't
hate the people who like them I've heard
you say that you know we can disagree
and still be friends we have a lot in
common we were both shit-canned by major
broadcast network I would write I wish
it can buy ABC you wish it can buy NBC
yeah it's not the worst thing in the
world but that happens to you and I tell
you when that happened to you I was
angry for you honestly because this
canceled culture it's so funny when they
do polls they find like 80 to 90% of the
people in this country hate this [ __ ]
yep even liberals hate this [ __ ] this is
one reason why Trump got elected because
people hate political correctness so
much that'll even take it in the mouth
of a werewolf like that when he's not
politically because he's a fighter and
that comes in right but when individual
instances come up everybody is so afraid
to stand up I remember I mean you even
apologized for something that I didn't
think was that awful it's like why can't
you just say okay I was a little
inartful about how I expressed that my
bad I'm sorry move on with our lives
instead of no you have to go away for
all time Wow well who are these perfect
people who have never made any mistake
I mean my own take on it is the
country's going through something right
now you know that marginalized groups
are rising up and trying to find
positions at the table equal positions
and that is that's a good thing the
difference is in approach how do we do
it and I and I understand this fight
because as a woman and somebody who's
you know been in the position I was in
that we talked about I have also felt
marginalized at times and like I don't
have an equal footing but the question
is do we do it with grace and humanity
and understanding that people make
mistakes and that we're all imperfect
and we're gonna screw up maybe maybe
more than once charity right and
kindness and an understanding that we're
all only here for a limited time and we
can't expect a perfect school it's
what's going is it the people who hate
bullying are always bullying you know
like have you even talked about this
it'll only make it worse that's bullying
the people who love diversity except of
opinion there's only one true appeal
that's what the right half of the
country is worried about they wonder
where the ideological diversity is right
because I mean I I think people they do
it too
of course and they're and they're
[ __ ] snowflakes do they do it exactly
they're not they're gross because what
because all they care about is getting a
scalp on the walls I don't care if
you're really a racist which you're not
they don't care about a million things
that's what they care about and and they
always want to find the worst version of
what any person is I just want to
believe yes the worst possible
interpretation about this well that's
like what President Obama was saying
right that that's not activism with your
thumbs on your on your phone and pretend
you have never committed a sin and never
will commit a sin right right like I'll
just sit in judgment of ever of everyone
and that wrote like one of the great
things about this country is the younger
generations have typically helped the
older generations understand new ways of
looking at things like that's how we've
evolved take gay marriage that's one
thing like hey you know maybe the way
you were looking at this wasn't so cool
maybe there's another way we could live
and and recognize each other's love and
and they never just cancelled the
generation that came before them because
they didn't in need
we agree or start talking about the
issues in the way they wanted I mean if
that were the case we wouldn't have had
an Obama second term Obama wasn't for a
gay marriages first term right yeah and
so I feel like somehow we have to get
back to talking to each other so there's
buy-in so people feel heard and we allow
for disagreement respectful kindness so
if we I don't have time to get to Trump
I think we would disagree about that a
little and that would be okay so I hope
you come back and we'll talk about that
thanks for having me all right thanks
[Applause]
you